[Music]
all right good morning everyone
welcome to the last day of next thanks
for joining us for the dev 109 session
on accelerating time to market with
api's and micro services cool so I'm
Matt Steele I'm a digital engagement
lead with Google cloud and I'm going to
kick off this session I know you really
want to hear from our friends at Equifax
David Stephens who heads up architecture
is going to discuss their API journey
and finally we have an awesome demo by
dharmendra who goes by DP and he's going
to show the new Equifax developer
experience that launched a few weeks ago
so I live in Mobile Alabama which is
pretty far from just about every Google
office and most of our large customer
sites I travel almost every week for
work to meet prospects and customers and
when I start each week I'm sitting on an
airplane at the end of a runway and
acceleration is extremely important for
me to get to where I need to be so why
is acceleration important to enterprise
IT and the business after years of
experimentation agile has finally gone
mainstream companies inside and outside
Silicon Valley are using some form of
this methodology in their software
development lifecycle to enable rapid
building and frequent delivery of
software updates with continuous
integration under this approach
companies are seeing increased
productivity within their app dev teams
faster release of digital products and
improved customer experiences all with
reduced cycle times and improved
productivity
so how our micro-services
revolutionising app development along
with the rise of cloud computing and
agile the increasing use of micro
services has profoundly affected how
enterprises developed software micro
services enable businesses to innovate
faster development teams can
independently develop deploy and scale
components of large applications the
adoption of cloud containers and CI CD
tools has made micro services
implementations much easier leading to
more and more modern software being
built as a set of micro services app
development teams implement micro
services using a variety of stacks like
kubernetes and Netflix OSS depending on
their needs and all of these micro
services use web api is as a mechanism
to communicate with one another so both
the concept of an api and the concept of
micro service involve structure and
interactions of software a micro service
can be misconstrued as simply an
endpoint to provide an API but micro
services have much more flexibility and
capabilities than that an easy way to
think about an API is you know it's
basically a contract of actions you can
request for a particular service API is
our in use today in a multitude of web
apps such as social media banking telco
healthcare and many more the
standardized contract allows for
external apps to interface with one
another and today we're in today's world
achives are usually developed using
restful style these safe guys have a
series of verbs associated with HTTP
actions like get post and put so the
apogee
api platform enables enterprises to
accelerate innovation provide shared
services and data and adapt to market
and customer needs api's have become the
foundation of that fast-moving digital
economy as customer expectations
increase companies need to be able to
meet those demands with flexible and
scalable technology Apogee applies
security and traffic management policies
and routes request to Micro sir
services while orchestrating your legacy
services and monolith apps so I'd like
to introduce you to David Stephens who's
going to speak to you about how he and
his team are accelerating time to market
with api's and micro services at Equifax
thank you thanks good morning everyone
if you're like me it's Thursday it's
been a long week we're all starting to
get a little tired so feel free to kick
back relax fall asleep don't listen to
anything we're about to say if you are
from Equifax I would try to get you to
go ahead and leave so DP and I are
subject to instant and infinite ridicule
but I don't think I'll get any takers so
I am the chief architect for Equifax
what that means is that actually work
with a team a globally dispersed team of
architects who are all experts in
variety of disciplines who are working
to define where we're going what we're
doing how we're doing it and and build
the equifax of the future so while we
talk about the equifax of the futures
because we have well the equifax of of
yesterday right we're in the middle of a
transformation the equifax of yesterday
is is an amazing company very large a
lot larger than people think
with multiple business units doing lots
of different things around the world and
they've been doing it for over a hundred
years right so certainly over the last
20-30 years as technology has really
become commonplace within the fence
serve in FinTech industries you know
they've done it we've done it
Equifax has done it the same exact way
the most fintechs have right so I've got
a white line here I can't cross so and
in what does that mean well you know
we've got a lot of mainframes we've got
lots of database systems we have lots of
custom built systems we have lots and
lots and lots of data centers we have
tons of redundancy and how things are
built what's being built what
capabilities are being driven we've got
you know amazing engineers working
around the world common you know all
working on roughly the same thing at the
same time and some in some places
and in there doing it in you know an
approach that swells adds to that right
it takes time right it it it's we've
introduced latency with our legate's
with our legacy within our development
methodologies and processes because of
the complexity and the complications
that we have within our scale so that
starts to drive us to where we are today
with with the transformation that were
on certainly folks know Equifax has had
some fun over the last couple of years
within that we've been driving a lot of
transformation investing a tremendous
amount of time money effort energy into
into that transformation starting with
security hardening making sure with this
vast array of systems that we have are
we doing the right things at the right
time in the right place do we have the
right controls and of course we do right
well we've we've got a powerful team
that's working through that at the same
time we're doing that we're starting to
start to revamp our our systems and how
how we're approaching those things and
so we started I don't know roughly about
a year ago with what's the last what's
the next stage of our technology
transformation how do we take how do we
take all of these things and do
something a little bit different flip
each one of these things on their head
customly a custom assembled not custom
built right common technology stacks not
disparate technology stacks well
documented discoverable services
available in a self you know
self-service model rapid onboarding of
customers and consumers days weeks
minutes hours not days year months and
years highly agile adaptable work
streams in a constantly evolving
capability that doesn't necessarily
require our consumers and customers
constant to constantly evolve with us
but they can adopt as they need to right
we won't want to enable not disrupt our
customers but at the same time we need
to give them more give our consumers
more on a minute my by minute basis and
not say hello
wait six months to get something and so
you know there's a lot of aspects to
that so we sat down and the first thing
we did is is developed an idea of a
micro services based architecture we
have a lot of commonality around the
globe of how we do things so we said
well let's break those things into
capabilities those capabilities into
discrete micro service you remember
Matt's slide which we call our common
core services framework it takes
discrete capabilities moves those and
then how do we didn't have those be
system-to-system conversations as
opposed to you know human to two system
conversations etc and and so we said
okay well got it micro services perfect
makes sense capabilities we aligned to
those tons of them that we're gonna be
that we're breaking into those we said
well we've got to have a way to connect
all of that right we've got to have a
way to implement that strategy on a
global scale and focus on the
capabilities that drive that value how
do we develop and deploy those reusable
micro services how do we let come let
both internal and external consumers
meaning our dev teams our product groups
our product alliances our customers take
those things stitch them together to
build the capabilities that they need do
it without requiring tons of
customization of code but really
configurable capabilities create a
consistent experience across all that
simplify the formats right make data
available whether you want to consume it
you might want to consume you might not
want to consume it do it all in a
governed manner you can imagine if any
of your in FinTech regulatory issues
we've got them out the wazoo and so we
have to have systems that allow for that
discrete sort of management of those
policies reduce the response times on on
on getting data you know you think about
your you know stack that includes
you know 13 hops to get to you know
route data and everything that has to be
done in between you're talking about
some substantial transaction time so how
do we reduce that how do we then also
take all of these things reduce the risk
on our back-end stability how we do it
with security from the ground up
built in not bolted on so we turn all
those into requirements we said okay
well that that's our requirements for
how we're going to do this this thing
with api's and stitching are our
microservices together so that
ultimately we can reduce that time to
integration improve our speed to market
have that faster response time lower our
maintenance cost have shorter feedback
loops right have more rapidly available
capabilities to the marketplace to the
tooth are it both internally and
externally eating our own dog food if
you will right so so we said okay well
we got to create a framework for our
strategy we said well okay first let's
establish a digital strategy we've kind
of kind of did that we aligned our
organization and culture so we were very
very monolithic in our architecture a
very monolithic in our across multiple
monoliths if you will in the way our
technology teams were going us we we
said you know what if we're gonna we're
gonna go with a instead of following
Conway we're gonna beat him over the
head a little bit and say listen let's
you know if we're gonna build this
around Microsoft let's build our teams
and dedicate teams to owning and
building those micro services build it
on and operate it run true sre model for
everything we're doing you know in total
culture shift for the company right
which of course you can't just replace
the culture you have to guide it
transform it and tweak it and move it
along so that became part of our
strategy we had to go out look and
evaluate and and and build or deploy
supporting technologies right GCP other
cloud providers will go unnamed the
tools that they provide whether they're
managed services whether their
capabilities where there's
simply run you know infrastructure and
as a service type things and then we had
to engage our partner ecosystem you know
to make sure that we're doing the right
thing and learn from each other we're
learning from our customers our
customers are learning from us we're
learning from our partners our partners
are learning from us you know we have
Google teams deep in the bowels of the
company who are embedded in helping us
do a lot of things one of those things
being of course implementing a pachinko
so that sort of set up our framework
right and set up our thing he says ok
well then what's our what is our
strategy is api's everywhere a ps4
everything everything is API it's not
you're not going even internally we want
to ensure that this service is talking
to that service everybody's using a
common logging monitoring metering
services everybody's using cominis if
you need this capability that service is
discoverable the Swagger's are out there
you grab it and deploy it run with it
internally open sourced right so if you
need to extend it you can extend it
govern it back into the company the team
that owns it and and do all this to
basically what it says up there is is
kind of rapidly enable those
capabilities and minimize the investment
right it's what all of our CFOs are
looking for and so that's what we're
trying to it's certainly what we want
makes our lives easier improves our
quality of life improves our quality of
service to our customers improves the
quality of service to our investors and
our partners drive high levels of
automation be able to incorporate more
scope faster be a lot more efficient how
we're doing things be able to
personalize those API swearnet you know
through configuration be able to adapt
as you can as you want to as a customer
adapt those changes or not it's kind of
where are we well we started an API
program we defined our microservices
architecture we start an API program to
work it we started a tribe call it
center of excellence here but we call
them internally we call it tribes if
you're familiar
Spotify morning we start a tribe there's
actually defining those things we have a
product Alliance who owns the product
aspect the external aspect of it we have
an internal product things actually
defining hey you know what you
development team X you know what do you
need out of our capability we started
both internal and partner api's so that
we can start leveraging pushing those
globally with the centralized governance
of these things so instead of everybody
getting to do whatever they want
whenever they want however they want we
said well no here's some guardrails
principals we don't want to be overly
prescriptive but we also don't want to
be overly hands-off right so you end up
with sprawl and disparate you know
disparate technologies and right back to
the problem state when we had in the
first place so we said let's not do that
let's actually have some governance
around how these things are done when to
drive the adoption right heavily through
you know discovery every tribe every
micro service has a page and our Service
Catalog says hey here's what we do
here's who we are here's who our support
infrastructure here so you call here so
it owns it here's who designed it here's
the link to the source code here's the
swagger right here's some example code
here's how you do this and said in
that's internally right where are we on
that journey well we're down it right
we're we're we've got a long way to go
but that's what we're doing and we are
making strong headway in that and what
our that's helping us do is actually
define that okay if we want our
customers to engage whether they're
furnishing data or consuming data from
us we want them to engage the same way
right it's a partner ecosystem within as
developers so that's helping us define
the capabilities and the requirements
that we need that we have around our
gateway platform right ultimately that
helps us transform that customer
acquisition I think we're doing ok right
we've got some early stuff and EDP is
going to give us a demo here in a short
bit right I think we're doing ok right
we've got company
Tribes rather that are in the product
alliances are really starting to grasp
onto it and it's a struggle a little bit
right we've got to operate the old keep
that running while we build the new the
new we're not we're not really evolving
code we're we're completely replacing it
which makes for a lot of fun
but it's going okay right we're pretty
excited about it there's a lot of folks
in here from the architecture team and
the technology leadership team who I
wish weren't in the room but you know
they're you know these are all folks
that are engaged every minute of every
day and actually making this come to
life in the amount of passion that we
have in doing it is been pretty amazing
because we're doing this on a global
scale a lot of people don't realize this
you might all but a lot of people don't
realize that
Equifax is not just a US company right
we are global we're in 24 countries
we're doing things we're the credit
industry actually exists everywhere in
the world in some form or fashion
sometimes it's positive sometimes is
negative sometimes it's this and you
know the way those things work but it
actually exists everywhere right now 124
of those countries Middle East Asia
North America South America Australia
and New Zealand Canada were kind of all
over the place and so as we it and we're
doing things jump beyond just you have
credit reports right we do business
intelligence and employment verification
we do identity and fraud services we're
on the largest holders of identity in
the world 1.5 billion unique or
something like that I don't know if I
put somebody on the spot I think it's
something 1.5 billion people within our
scope right so we're providing that on
global scale well so we needed a
solution we needed a platform that would
that would meet that global scale it
would meet that availability requirement
on providing access to all of these
services and these capabilities
providing access to the data in a govern
model and that's where we settled one
Apogee
and use that as the core for our
framework right and how we're producing
those producing those services out to
the market we're running that all over
the world we have multiple regions we're
running in multiple providers we are
fairly leaning heavily towards the GCP
stack at this point everybody read our
earnings call that I think the most used
word was Google but we have to be
multi-cloud certainly everybody knows
Apogee Zorin or you know where it came
from we have a lot runnel AWS we have a
lot run in here we have a lot run in
there
and and that's fine it adds some
complexity but adds this makes sure that
we're actually paying attention and
doing things the right way because this
is the kind of stuff that we're
producing through it right these are
some of the things I mentioned that we
have lots of different types of clients
of our developer portal the customers
mobile web our service our internal
services framework that's the bottom
when they got kind of cut off there
that's our internal users of the same
thing all right all going through a
gateway which is providing us governance
authentication analytics monetization
etc in a framework that is not custom
built right everybody's familiar with it
easily familiar can be easily familiar
with it and we're published pushing our
Swagger's out all over the place so that
people can get it and actually onboard
onto the developer portal dps gonna show
you in a minute because we're providing
this type of stuff right like a Mitch an
asset well you know verification I did
anybody know we do all these things
besides if you're not at Equifax a lot
of people think we're just credit but
we're so far beyond that and so we have
to be able to provide for a robust
methodology to to integrate like I said
we're down that journey we launched our
dev portal publicly launched our dev
portal as DP I don't know how long ago
it was but we're already on boarded and
of customers into that they're starting
to use it we're starting to see some
really great results out of it just as
we are today you know we're reducing the
design of some of those api's for things
that would take months because we're
going a lot more discreet and we're
doing this on a micro services way we're
down to you know a week we're reduced
we're reducing that time to market in a
lot of cases we've got improves
drastically improved security we were
already in good shape but it's bolted on
right now we're building it from the now
we're doing it it's just inherent in
what we're doing we're enabling our
customers who are self-service portal
big deal love our customers customers
love us most of the time but they really
are starting especially in the banking
industry they're starting to move from
being don't ever go on to the cloud just
like hey Equifax what are you doing you
know can you help us
right we're weirdly helping them move
down these paths then we have some banks
and some and some customers they take
the credit Karma's and the you know the
the cap ones and stuff they're far
beyond us and they're begging us to move
forward well this is us being able to
now start help them and and do this
instead of a batch process running over
SFTP you know we're going to API to API
which drastically changes the
performance and the interaction that we
have with them and ultimately the
satisfaction which is fantastic and then
we're getting a lot more visibility
we're already starting to see and learn
and discover things about how we were
doing those you know looking forward you
know we're releasing a lot of industry
specific product Suites talent
verification services for human
resources our government services that
are coming through our largest division
us is open up the data hub concept which
is being able to open up data sources
and a very protected and regulated
manner to to the outside world that of
course you can imagine has a lot of
things around it but you know what data
exchange is what the world's about right
so
we are one of the largest keepers of
data we want to enable the market to be
able to use that to improve consumer
life improve customer improve business
you know prove whatever your use case
might be so I think with that we'll ask
Dharmendra DP it's easier to say to come
set up his demo real quick and I think
after that we'll take a couple of
questions
okay yeah thank you David and good
afternoon everyone nah i'm Thurman's
repair ahah I go by DP and I'm the
digital experience leader at Equifax I
manage a team that manages the API
gateway platform and we build all the
products and solutions on it and just to
give you guys a background so we started
this whole API journey almost three to
four years back and it was last year
under the leadership of our CTO Bryson
we really accelerated the program and we
rolled out the first beta version of our
developer portal so I'm going to show
you um what we have built our whole API
platform the developer portal and for us
it has been a real game-changer for us
and our customers the way we can
integrate our customers can integrate to
our api's and we can expose these API
Zen products to them was a real game
changer
so it it was a win-win for both us and
our customers so I'm going to go over
the demo I'll show you the whole portal
and some of the backend services that we
have and we'll be taking questions at
the end of the session and so Matt told
me there is a Dory online Dory that you
guys can go in and you know if you have
any questions you can post it there so
our API portal the developer portal we
call it is is an interface to all our
API sand products to our developers and
customers so if I'm going to go and jump
into the developer portal here which is
developer Equifax comm so that's our
developer portal so traditionally our
customers and business partners and
developers typically get this URL maybe
from a sales contact or business contact
they might pass on this URL developers
will go in there and you know check out
this portal right the other way is what
typically most of the people do these
days is just go to google write and
search for these so me as a developer
let's say I go into
one of the best search engine Google out
there and I look for as a developer I
want to see what API is Equifax has
right so you would just type Equifax API
so it's going to show them our developer
portal right here on the first link
right you click on this this takes you
to our portal so now I as a developer is
into the portal and I'm just looking at
looking through the different sections
here so you have all the products that
we have listed you know some
documentation here on how to get started
and some information on how you can
contact us in case you have any issues
or questions right so since we have
rolled out the beta version we have a
lot lot more products right now that are
being rolled out to the portal for this
beta version we have rolled out a suite
of inserted products that we have and in
start touch is our it's a flagship
frictionless pre-fill consumer or the
authentication and prefilled solution so
we can identify a consumer purely based
on his device with real-time integration
with our telecom partners and Equifax
data asset so you don't have to go
through this whole process of filling up
your entire information your name
address other details verify your
identity like all this manual process is
completely eliminated you know it's just
few keystrokes seven keystrokes I
believe is all you you know some basic
information we need and we can
authenticate and we can pre-fill all
your information so it's a really cool
product it goes by the name in start
touch and instruct touch ID is is the
product that does the consumer identity
verification and prefilled and then we
have additional products that are built
on top of instructors once we have
verified your identity we can provide
you additional liquefaction eita assets
like pre screen off first app a where we
can pull in your credit card and
actually use that to make a payment
employment your account on file and that
sector all right so we have a lot of
these products that are built on top of
them you know once the pre-fill
and authentication is complete we can
provide you additional Equifax data
assets so let's say I as a developer
going here and I click on this link to
learn more about this product it gives
you an overview and some benefits and
details around what the API does and at
this point you know the developer really
wants to go and dig into the API right
because that's what developer want hey
give me show me the specifications the
API is the request response so for the
developer if he is really interested in
getting into the specifications you know
he has to sign into the portal so this
is where we have a link here where the
developer can go in and register for an
account on the developer portal and
everything here is self so you know the
moment you go in here you fill in your
information you accept the terms and
conditions and you register you
immediately get an email notification
saying hey your account is created
verify your registration create a
password and you'll have a credentials
created right away to log into the
portal so one thing I want to mention
here is we have two forms of the
registration one is an individual
registration and then we have company
registration and typically we recommend
our partners and customers and
developers to register as a company
because that gives you a lot more
benefit in terms of once you have a
company account you can go and add other
developers into your company
subscription so you don't have to come
to us you can just manage your own
account you can add more developers any
subscription that you create all your
developers in your company has shared
that right so it's all completely self
so and we have a few additional things
that come with a company subscription
which I'm going to show you but ideally
we recommend going in and signing up as
a company so once you have created your
credentials I'm going to login to the
portal with with my credentials right
now
okay so once you are logged in it will
show your name here and you can go back
and see the same products here I'm going
to go back to in start touch ID and now
I can actually go in and click on their
technical specifications so here once
you come in here it actually gives you
the entire API specifications in a
completely open a is open API
specification format you can just click
on this developers can download the API
specifications they can play around with
it on the left here it shows a list of
API is that you need to call for the
authentication and prefilled insert
touch ID solution and the good thing
here is once you click on these api's
it's going to show the customer or the
developer pretty much all the
information that he needs to pass to the
API right so it has all the details
around what goes in the request the
headers the payload what kind of fields
there are what are you know like what
type of field it is and it shows you
what the response is going to look like
what will come back from the API and on
the on the right here it actually shows
you a sample request and response also
so a real really cool feature here on
all these API is is a try out link right
so I can just click on this link and the
developer can on this portal right here
make an API call to our back-end sandbox
environment and get a response back so
he can actually test these API is right
here from the browser make a call all
the way to the Google a Pidgey platform
gateway into the backend target endpoint
get a response back and get it back here
on the browser so I'm going to show you
how to do that so once you go back to
the getting started right so there are a
list of things already listed on how to
go about executing these API is right so
the first thing we recommend or we you
actually have to do is subscribe to the
products you know because there are
certain things that need to be created
before you can make a call to these API
so so essentially what happens is all
these api's are protected by Oh
- OH authorization tokens so you really
need to have an authorization token
before you can make an API call to any
of these products that we have here so
to get a token you need to subscribe to
the product and then generate a token so
I'm going to go and click on the
subscribe and I already have one
subscription but I'm going to create one
more so you just go in here click on
request subscription you pick the
products that you want to subscribe to
I'm going to let's say I'm going to pick
in stretch ID and you can pick more than
one products here so once you click
Submit at this point me as a developer
has already subscribed to the product it
act you know we actually have created a
subscription in a completely self sub
model and the customer or the developer
can actually click on their subscription
here this is the one that just got
created and it will actually show them
all the credentials that are created for
them to generate a or to authorization
token right so now I go back and I'm
going to get go ahead and create a token
or token that I need for the API calls
so I just click on the token API call
I'm going to just take one of the
existing so now here you can actually do
a tryout you fill in your information
the client ID and secret that you
created in the in the subscription
before just put those values in here
make a call this goes to the backend
system in real time makes a call to the
open Auto auth authorization service and
it will come back with our token so this
is access access token that I have got
from the OAuth service alright now I
just take this token and I can go ahead
and make API calls to any of these API
ice so I'm going to show you something
else here
so let me put this token API call okay I
can make a call so this actually sends
you all the response back from the
sandbox environment so
the developer actually made a request
send it all the way to the backend and
got a response back so what I'm going to
show you now is the backend system right
so this is our Google Appaji gateway and
what I'm going to show is show you as
typically what happens is whenever
customers are testing these api's either
in the sandbox or you know test
environment or production they have lot
of these challenges right where they're
having issues they want us to
troubleshoot it has been um you know
very challenging for us to really
troubleshoot and figure out hey where it
is you know looks like we have given you
the right specifications but they are
not getting the right response so a
really cool feature that comes out of
the box and happy G like David and Matt
mentioned it has a lot of things that
come with the platform right but one of
the cool things that I want to show you
is and that has really helped us in
troubleshooting our customers issues
real time through the Gateway is it's
called a trace functionality so I'm
going to go in here pull up the backend
API
and I'm going to click on the trace link
here so when I say this API and enable
trace I can actually go and start a
trace so at this point anything that is
coming to this sandbox API is going to
be recorded and it will actually show me
what's happening or where it's failing
or is it successful so now I go back
here and I'm going to make the same API
call again from the browser so this time
it should actually show me the entire
trace
okay this is really cool because what
what it shows me here is this is where
the request came in to the backend
Apogee gateway I can click on this it
shows me all the headers that came into
the gateway if I go down it shows me the
entire payload that was sent from the
customer or the developer in this case I
was the one who was actually sending it
from the browser she shows you all the
data here and then it shows you a list
of policies so we have a lot of security
policies that we execute against this
API is right so these are the policies
it's showing me that it's executing all
the security policies if you have
standard policies we have spiked arrest
rate monitoring quota API is IP
whitelisting and
you know pretty much all these APs and
you can actually click on these
different policies you can get details
of how long it took to execute these
policies if you want to go and tweak
these policies and then once the
policies are passed the request goes to
the backend sandbox environment and this
is where again it shows the same thing
here to show you all the headers and
payload that was sent to the backend
this is a response
it shows you what came back from the
from the target endpoint which is a
sandbox endpoint and then this is what
is the response that actually sent back
to the customer so it's going to show
you what response was sent back so this
is really cool I mean this to me I mean
it I really like this feature you know
it gives you complete insights into
what's happening when the api's are
flowing through the platform you can
trace through everything tells you how
much you know in terms of performance it
shows you how long it's taking to
execute these policies and then you know
all the details that you get with a
trace here and in fact I'm going to go
back and maybe change the token here
okay and so if I send this request to
the backend it actually failed right so
I can go back here and I can look at the
trace so if you see the trace there at
that I ran before past all the checks
and went to the backend and came back
with a response but here just just
looking at this right I know it failed
right here you know I
see this mark here and it says that hate
failed in the the token authorization
token validation so this has been really
cool okay so let me go back and show you
another feature that we have built for
our customers is so our customers right
once they have tested their API is
against the sandbox
they have built their client
applications tested everything they are
all good and they want us to promote
their subscription to the test
environment right test all integration
all that is completely self so they
don't have to reach out to us all they
need to do is they just go back here
into their subscription go into their
company subscription and creating the
subscription is the same process that I
showed you earlier all you need to do is
go and say a request subscription pick
the products create your subscription
but here once they have created a
subscription this is an existing
subscription I created they are in the
sandbox right now once they have tested
and they want to promote the
subscription to that test all they need
to do is just go in here and click this
button select it you know few fields of
information here enter their IPS for
white listing and they submit the
request that's it at this point the
Equifax product team gets a request they
approve it and their entire subscription
is now available in test for them to do
a integration testing ok let me show you
since I was on the back end I just want
to quickly show you a few things here
that you know we really like with the
RPG platform is the reports all right so
I'm going to go back and show you some
of the reports that have you know been
really nice to look at which is
especially the developer englishmen so
what this does is it actually shows me
shows me a list of developers and apps
and how many developers have registered
how many apps they are building and
these numbers were really nice to look
at you know we see like lot of
developers are coming in they are trying
these API is they are building their
products so all that statistics I can
pull right here so
if I look at it we just rolled it out
but I'm seeing that we already have 1334
developers 179 applications have been
built from these developers and this is
all from what date just one day right so
you know this is the kind of enablement
we are doing for our customers and
developers where we are really seeing
people coming in and trying these api is
creating their apps another cool thing
that you can see in the report is the
geo map this actually shows you across
the world where all our developers are
building these apps and where all they
are accessing our applications so if I
click on United States it would actually
even show me what stage they are coming
from and I can go back to a week and I
can see that you know we have developers
all these different areas coming in and
building API is or applications against
our API
ok so I think that is all I had for the
demo one thing I want to say is so
whatever I showed you in the last 15
minutes is where a developer comes in
suprised us to the portal subscribes to
an API goes through the documentation
have all the specifications try these
API is out against the live sandbox
environment and then create their
subscription and push them to a testing
integration environment and the same
process they can even push it to
production surety and 15 minutes would
take us weeks and weeks of manual work
traditionally in the old legacy ways and
you know it if not months it would take
us weeks and weeks of work so this has
really accelerated and enabled our
customers to integrate with our API sand
products much much faster
[Music]